this video is going to be a quick review
of complex numbers
if you studied complex numbers in the
past this will knock off some of the
rust and it'll help explain why we use
complex numbers in electrical
engineering
if complex numbers are new to you i
highly recommend you go look on the khan
academy videos that sal's done on
complex numbers and those are in the
algebra 2 section
so let's get started the the complex
numbers are based on the concept of the
imaginary
j the number j in electrical engineering
we use the number j instead of i
and j squared is defined to be
minus one
so that's that's the definition
of j
and that's referred to as an imaginary
number
i don't really like the name imaginary
but that's what we call it it's a really
useful concept in electrical engineering
so with that definition we define a
complex number and the usual variable we
often use for that is a z
and
a complex number has a real part we'll
call that x
and it has an imaginary part that we're
going to call j y
so j is explicit out here this is the
imaginary part of the number this is the
real part of z
so based on what this number looks like
this suggests that we can maybe plot
this on a two-dimensional plot and we'll
call this the complex plane
and the complex plane looks like this
we can plot two parts we'll have a real
part over here
on what is usually the x-axis and we'll
have an imaginary part
which is the vertical axis so this is
this is referred to as the complex plane
and if i have a complex number z i could
represent it on this plane
by basically going over x like this
going over a distance x
and up a distance y
that will give me an imaginary number
and that's z
so z is a location in this complex
space and that's one representation of a
complex number
so the other common way to represent a
complex number
is by drawing a line from the origin
here and going right through z
like that
and then we basically have
some radius r from the origin to
distance out to z
and it's measured by some angle like
that
and that angle would be theta
so in the orange is r and theta and in
the blue here we have x and y and those
are two different ways to represent
exactly the same number z
so over here i can say
i can say z
equals r
at some angle this angle symbol
of theta
now i can go over here and i can work
out
how do we convert between the two how do
i convert from r to y and x and how do i
go the other way
so one thing i notice is i just use some
simple trigonometry
so this distance here if i know r say i
know r this distance here x
is equal to the cosine of theta
times the distance r
r cosine theta so i can say x equals r
cosine of theta
so if i want to figure out the y
distance here and i know r already
let me just move here's here's the y
distance right here i can say y equals
r
times the sine
of theta
that's this distance here
okay so if i know r and theta this is
how i get x and y
now let's go the other way suppose i
know
x and y
and i want to know r and theta so r this
is a right triangle here there's our
right triangle
so i use the pythagorean theorem so to
convert from x and y to r
i use the pythagorean theorem
r
squared equals
x squared plus y squared
and now if i want to find theta i use
another little bit of trigonometry
tangent is
opposite over adjacent
opposite over adjacent is y over x
so tangent of theta
equals
y over x
so if you're going to do this on your
calculator you would say that theta
equals the inverse tangent
of
y over
x
so there's two conversions between
two different forms of the of the
of the complex number
we want to be able to use these
conversions and we want to be able to
use either of these two representations
freely and go back and forth between
them
now there's a third representation
that's also going to be really useful to
us now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take this x and y expression here and
i'm going to put it back into
this way this this rectangular way of
writing z
what that looks like is
z equals x is
r
times cosine theta
and y
is equal to r i'll put the r out front
here
r
sine theta
with a j in front of it
so i can write
plus j
sine theta
now if you look closely at this
expression right here
we recognize this we recognize this as
one side of euler's formula
and the other side of euler's formula i
can rewrite z as
r times e
to the j
theta
and this is called the exponential form
of a complex number
all this means what does this mean here
what is this thing this means exactly
the same thing as this and this is one
of the two ways we can write complex
numbers so this r e to the j theta that
is z
right here that means
a complex number
sitting out here at at radius r from the
origin at angle theta that's what you
think of when you see
e to the j something written down it's
it's just a representation of a complex
number
and this this form is going to be
particularly useful because if you
remember when we were solving all those
differential equations
we always liked exponential solutions
so i want to put some squares around
these guys these are the three ways
that we can represent
a complex number and they're all
equivalent
and i'll go over here just as a reminder
note i'll write down
euler's formula
that's where that comes from
and let me write that down over here
euler's formula is
e to the j
theta
equals cosine theta
plus
j
sine theta
the other form has a negative exponent
e to the minus j theta
equals cosine theta
minus
j sine theta
so that's euler's formula
and sal has videos on on how to derive
this equation
and you would search on this term here
in khan academy